- Do your parents listen to your podcast?
- They do now.
- They're trying, well yes.
- We had to teach them
how to download a podcast
'cause they'd never
done it before.
- Oh, I didn't even
think about that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they do now.
- I called home and my mom,
I was like, "Mom, what are you doing?"
And she said, "I'm watching
your podcast on YouTube."
And I said, "Mom, we're not on YouTube."
"Well, yes you are."
And I was like, I called my sister Janet.
I was like, "where do you
have Mom on the internet?"
Be careful, because you know YouTube--
- You find stuff on there.
- But we're not,
we're not on YouTube.
- You can put all of us
ladies in, and you never know
what's gonna come up.
- You never know.
I was like, "don't let
Mom search YouTube."
- (laughing) I just picture it.
That's amazing.
So this is your mom,
was that your mom watching?
- Oh, this is it.
- Oh yeah, we made a video
of ourselves--
- That was my mom
and my sister, Janet.
- Teaching our family how
to download a podcast.
- You can't watch the podcast on YouTube.
- Is your sound on your phone?
Is your sound on?
♪ Da da da da, da da da da ♪
- Oh, my god.
- What were you guys watching?
- Wesley or something like that.
- So I'm gonna teach you
how to download a podcast.
- We got a pen and a paper,
we're gonna write it down.
- Where's Mom going?
- Oh my gosh, I love, there
should be a show about that.
Just older people getting into technology,
I would watch that.
- Well, the first time
my mom sent me an email,
she called me and she
said, "why haven't you
"responded to my email?"
And I said, "well, what email did you,
"address did you send it to?"
And she said, "well, it
said to, and I wrote Jenna."
(audience laughing)
- Just find her.
- Just Jenna.
- Not even at anything.
Just Jenna, she wrote a
long letter and hit send.
I was like, "Mom, it
doesn't work like that.
"I never got it."
- Oh my god, I love it.
- I would do that.